okay let's start okay um
welcome everyone to the ddps seminar uh
before we introduce our invited speaker
let's go over
some rules and logistics uh first of all
please mute yourself during the talk
unless you have questions if you have
questions you are welcome to unmute and
ask
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them in 20 session at the end
second today's gdpr seminar is open to
external audiences therefore no
classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out and finally the talk
today will be recorded and uploaded
in our youtube channel uh that's about
it now let me introduce our speaker
today it is an honor to hold host
kaushik
batacharya who is
our
tyson senior professor of mechanical and
professor of material science as well as
the vice provost at the
caltech
he received his bachelor's degree from
the indian institute of the technology
madras india in 1986
his ph.d
from the university of minnesota
minnesota in 1991 and his post-doctoral
training at the current institute for
mathematical sciences during 1991-1993
he joined caltech in 1993
his research concerns
the mechanical behavior of materials and
specifically uses theory
to guide the development
development of new materials
he has received the von carmen medal of
the society of industrial and applied
mathematics in 2020 distinguished alumni
award of the indian institute of
technology
in
the outstanding achievement award of the
university of minnesota in 2018
the warner culture medal of the american
society of mechanical engineering in
and the graduate student council
teaching
and the mentoring award at caltech in
2013.
today kaushik will
give a talk with the title of
multi-scale modeling and neural
operators
please expect a wonderful talk and enjoy
it
now without further adieu let me pass
the button to kausik
by asking our usual question that is
what is your favorite things to do other
than research
well i'm looking at it i'm actually
staring out of my window into the
mountains
behind so
going for walks in these mountains is
probably what i do
very nice very nice getting some fresh
air right for sure yeah
okay the stage is yours
thank you um thank you
yang zhu uh it's a great pleasure to be
here and um even though it's virtual and
share with you some of
the kind of fun we've been having over
the last two or three years
uh all of this is largely
a collaboration with andrew stewart
who's an applied mathematician at
caltech and anima anand kumar
who is a computer science also at
caltech
along with a large group of really
wonderful and really sharp students in
postdocs
the work i'll talk today about uh
is largely the work of nikola kovacky
who's a graduate student in applied math
with uh
andrew stewart
uh brigade liu who is a postdoctoral
scholar with me
and is now on the faculty at
cambridge university
margaret trottner who is a graduate
student also with andrew
zhongyi lee who was a graduate student
with anima
kamiya aziz adena shelly who used to be
a postdoc with anima and now is on the
faculty at purdue i'll also mention
works by arju who's a graduate student
with me
ying shi tay who is used to be a
graduate student with me but now at
livermore
and akila raja so
so let me kind of tell you the kinds of
problems i'm interested in
one is
trying to understand the plasticity and
especially in the context of dynamics
the plasticity
of low symmetry materials like magnesium
magnesium is the lightest metal and has
very high strength
to weight ratio
but it's also very
um
it's not ductile so it has very limited
ductility
so what we'd like to understand
and the reason for it is that there's
very complex
individual slip systems
because it's a low symmetric crystal and
what we'd like to understand is how do
these flip system affect
the macroscopic behavior for example
when i'm doing some kind of dynamic
impact
calculation
as it gets filtered through the
polycrystalline
microstructure
second line of work quite distinct
but very similar
problems uh come in
interested in active materials and in
particular a class of materials called
liquid crystal elastomers
so these are rubber like solids but they
have pneumatic messages embedded in
their main rsi chains
and because of this interaction between
kind of the entropic rubber elasticity
and the physics of liquid crystals phase
transitions and liquid crystals they can
undergo large spontaneous deformations
and also form very strange domains
and have very unusual macroscopic
properties here i'm showing something
which happens if i take a rod and i
twist it
it ends up buckling in this particular
way so
and we're trying to understand the
macroscopic properties starting from
this kind of very small scale physics
which we understand well
here's another recent work
uh concerning dft
over the many years
michael ortiz and myself have been
trying to develop a method
of trying to do dft
studies of defects like dislocations
with the far field matter so we would
like to do
multi-million atom calculations of dft
so that you can fully resolve the core
and one of the ideas is really to do
some subgrid sampling of the electronic
fields
and
that means that we end up doing a lot of
unit cell calculations
and go
and that provides a kind of predictor or
a
pre-conditioner for this method so
so these are the kinds of problems that
i'm interested in
and so let me focus on the one on the
left
if i were to do a calculation like this
classically
i know the kind of balance laws of
continuum mechanics
but then i have to have a closure
relation which tells me the relationship
between
the deformation history at a point which
i'll call f of time
and the state of stress
and classically we have done this by
empirical constitutive laws and
they
have been
very helpful and useful they're still
very useful but we'd like to understand
more especially if you want to do the
inverse problem of trying to design the
material
and multi-scale modeling provides the
framework and the recipe of multi-scale
modeling is
you know the macroscopic
deformation gradient and its history
you use that
in a smaller scale calculation often
with periodic boundary conditions so at
the grain scale
you use this to provide you the boundary
conditions and then you solve this
smaller scale physics from there you
extract the stress history and use that
in the larger scale problem so it's the
small scale problem basically provides
you
with the
um small scale problem provides you with
the closure relation necessary for doing
the large scale calculations
okay and of course this is i'm
describing it only at two scales this
framework of multi-scale modeling works
at multiple scales
you can think of multiple scales going
all the way from electrons to your
macroscopic simulation
and the kind of intellectual
idea behind multi-scale modeling is that
any time you only have two skills
two scales
really communicating it's a pairwise
communication where the larger scale
regulates the lower scale by providing a
boundary condition
and then you filter the results of the
lower scale to the upper scale right and
so you can use this cascade and
so coming back to this
if i want to try and really do this what
i have to do is i have to do
a large number of repeated solutions of
the fine scale problem if i want to kind
of just take this philosophy and want to
implement it without thinking
what is called fe square times what i
have to do is at each grid point of my
macroscopic problem
i have to start a microscopic problem
solve it and put it back right so you
really need a lot of repeated solutions
so of course it's extremely
computational expensive
second you have an in problem of
generating representative
microstructures because you really are
not tracking all the details of the
microstructure of the small scale
problem
so based on some average you have to
somehow generate the small scale problem
and ultimately
you're doing these very large
calculations and you're using only a
very small portion of the information
right because you're filtering all this
away so you're doing these massive
calculations and then using it
so
the kinds of so this is what motivates
our work
so
if i think of this as a
map from
the deformation history to the stress
history can i use
use learn the solution operator of the
lower
scale problem
using the data generated by repeated
solutions so i solve this problem
repeatedly that provides my data can i
learn this map then
and in some ways can i also try to learn
some hidden physics or closure
relationship
from this data that i get by retreated
solutions
so those are the problems which motivate
me today
and that's kind of what i've been trying
to understand and that's what i'll talk
to you about today i wanted to
wanted to emphasize that our goal here
is really learning the solution operator
there is a large body of work that is
coming where you postulate what happens
here
and of course you don't know the
parameterization so you prima you
develop you postulate a parameterized
model and use machine learning for
learning the parameters right
that's not what i'm doing i really want
to learn the solution operator so
so that's something which i wanted to
emphasize here
okay
so this is the problem so i haven't
given
an input output map so i'm given the
strain history initial microstructure
and i want to find out the stress
history and the microglia
the first thing you realize is that this
is
in this case it's a strained history so
it's a function of time
so that's a function it's not discrete
data so it's infinite dimensional so the
maps we are interested in learning
is from
one function space to another so we're
really trying to learn a non-linear
operator right so these are function
spaces so these are infinite dimensions
and i think that's important
so the data we have is we don't know
this map but what we are trying to do is
we know realizations of this map so in
other words we know pairs
of input functions f
and output functions s
such that s is a function is
this map
and f is drawn from some distribution
which you may or may not know and that's
something which i'll talk a little bit
about right
so that's the data i have
and what i'm trying to do is to
find an operator psi which is
parameterized by some parameter
parameters theta
such that
there is some
value of this parameter theta star at
which this operator will approximate
this operator right
so the problem of training is the
following so from this data
i have to kind of postulate some
architecture here and use this data to
find the particular parameterization
that's the kind of
math problem i want to do
so it's completely supervised learning
with the given data coming from some
so i'll show you some examples of this
i'll talk a lot about what i'll call the
pca net and i'll mention
some really uh
recent work ongoing work which we're
very excited about rn on that and i'll
make some comments about other operator
other
methods of doing this
so what are the challenges in doing this
one is of course what is the
architecture that you should choose for
doing this
second
your data comes from either numerical
simulations or some experiment and it's
discrete so you don't really know the
full function you only often know
the function sampled on some finite grid
so you only know it projected on some
finite dimensional uh grading
but you might do a simulation i might do
a simulation it might be in different
uh
resolutions so we want the
operator to really learn the functional
relationship so we want it to be
independent of this kind of resolution
and when i'm trying to use it i might
want to use the resolution relevant for
my macroscopic calculation so it's also
very important therefore that this
operator that i find really be
represent the operator and therefore be
independent of the resolution of the
data that i have
and the third kind of challenge is
really trying to identify the
the distribution from which the data is
drawn so that's that's an important
thing okay
so the broad so
so let me begin i'll first begin by
introducing pcnet the one in which we
have explored the most
and then i will generalize down the road
to a broader architecture
which has a similar structure so
again we are trying to map the learn the
map from one function space to another
so here's the architecture we're going
to use
um and this is just what we postulate
and
on the upper right i have noted the name
of the student that the postdoc who did
bulk of the work and in this case this
is really the contribution of
nick kovacky
um
so you have a function space uh so you
have a map so you have a function space
f so what we're going to do is to do a
projection of it to a finite dimensional
space
and then i introduce a lifting back from
this finite dimensional space to the
original function space so you can think
of this as the pca
in which case
depending on the data you have you
choose
a basis set and represent your data and
that various asset and then of course
that provides you
also a lifting operator you could also
use a
kind of a deep neural net in terms of an
autoencoder for example right this is
the identity map and this is the
this is the
small dimensional layer in between
so that's what we do on on the input
space
we do the same on the output space again
we project and left
now i have a finite dimensional
representation of the of the input and
output space so i can use
my favorite uh
deep neural network or graph network or
whatever architecture i want to use
right so i'm going to
right okay and then so the overall
neural operator then is the projection
the finite dimensional network and then
the
uh lifting
so i can write it in some compact way in
this way
okay
okay so that's what we're going to do
and for this we can prove the following
result so before i show you some
numerics i'll actually tell you the kind
of results that we can prove
so we're going to assume for this
theorem
that these are hilbert spaces
we can now actually extend this result
to bomback spaces but we're going to
assume that the input and the output
spaces
have
a hilbert's page structure
we're going to assume that the map
that we are trying to approximate is
lipschitz
uh we can again uh
relax this
uh
so these are the are the projections and
the lifting are done through pca mu is a
probability measure on f which we know
then we say that given any
uh
parameter i can find dimensions for my
reduct reduce space and a set of
parameters for my neural network
such that the expected error
over all of the space f
expected over all choices of data
is going to be bounded
so that's kind of an approximation
theorem you can prove
and
i'll make a couple of comments notice
that we assume that we know the
probability measure from which our data
is sampled in actual problems that may
or may not be true
we need sufficient data for training
because this is basically saying that
the only way we can find bound the error
is by
taking some expectation over all
possible data
maybe i should have also mentioned here
that
what you can really do theoretically
like in all these kinds of approximation
theorems and
is really bound the expected error you
can't really bound the
absolute error or the maximum error you
can only bound some expected error
and you need some regularity in this
case elections right so
so let me
show you a very simple example
i'm looking i am
i have this partial differential
equation so the kind of a simple
you can call it uh elliptic problem a is
a positive number
and we are looking for the map
from this coefficient a of x
to the solution u of x right so that's
the map we are looking for
a might be in some h minus one you might
be in some l2 so it doesn't have the
hilbert's phase structure but okay
and we're going to sample this from some
distribution
so this is a of x
we solve this problem generate numerical
solutions on some grid
or 21 by 421
we down sample it to some dimension
and then use that to fit our
neural operator using a pca dimension
70 and some things like this okay
so here's the a of x here's the ground
truth of some particular u of x so this
is my data
and then in this particular case this
would be what the train operator would
be and that's the error so this is a
particular realization but more
generally let's look at it out here
okay
so what i have is the relative test
error average over so i train it
over some training data and this is
really the some separate test data and
this is the error in the test data
expected error
so though i do my simulations of 421
the data i use is down sample from there
and i use it for training at about
at 64. so i downsample it at 64.
and then i'm going to test it at 64 at
100 and all these other resolutions all
downsampled from the original data
and what you see is that our
architecture let's look at the blue one
where the
lower dimensional was 70.
you see that basically this does gives
you and resolution independent
error
the error is about five percent and it's
resolution independent
now
after downsample and um
and when you
you know computer relative error on the
higher resolutions
there is some missing points how how do
you compute the result
okay so the original data i generate is
at a very high resolution 428 that's 421
squared that's where i did my numerical
simulation right
right
very good
then what i do is i down sample that to
right 421 square to 64.
i train my neural operator
with that
right
and then i test it with
other test data at 64. but other test
data at 200 300 and so on so forth
so what this is showing you is though i
fitted it though i learned the operator
with 64
dimensional data
the operator actually learned the
solution operator which is resolution
independent and so if you have data
which is uh if you
test it against data which is at a
higher resolution it still does it
and the reason for this and where this
really this is really where the pca part
helps
so when i i'm not training the
architecture based on
the data that 64 i have but i did a pca
which tells me something about the
distribution of the data and i train my
neural network on that part so that's
why it becomes resolution independent
right and the black dot shows you if you
don't do this pca step just train it
directly on this data so
64 and you see the error really blows up
as you change resolution
so what so this architecture that i
showed you is what enables you to get
resolution independence
the neural operator you're you're you're
learning it's
it's mapping the continuous space to the
continuous space that's right okay
so i would expect that it will fall
apart if i go close to 421 square
because that's of course
the origin that's the only way only
thing i know about the operator but okay
but away from there it's quite recent
if i just did some kind of linear
regression this would be my error up
there
so you do much better than linear
regression
hope so
um okay
the other thing i'd want to show you is
something which is quite interesting so
when you do the pca the blue line so
let's start with the red line is for 30
dimensional red reduced to 30 dimension
if you use 70 dimensions you do better
the error drops but then if you use 150
dimensions you actually the error
increases
and the reason is that
at that resolution suddenly your the
network that you're using and the data
you're using did not train the network
well enough
so here's what shows you
this
so for a hundred uh so so this is
shows you the
training data set
and you can see that if your training
data is small
with blue
this is where you get the best
resolution then you go
but then if you increase the size of the
training data you can really reduce uh
the error
with using
uh higher dimensions so what it means is
that yes you can get better resolution
uh better learning with a higher
dimension
but you that also means that the amount
of training data you need to train that
network is much higher
so that's really a representation of
this expectation here
so
so there's some
you have to be careful
that
if you have a more complex network you
need more data to trade
so okay so i showed you some example i
don't know what this is
sorry about that
i showed you an example with um
the
uh with this uh elliptic operator this
is the example from dft work from
inkshi's thesis
so i'm here what we're doing is we're
taking a very simple problem i'm taking
a unit cell i'm deforming it by some f
so this is actually just a finite
dimensional map
and i calculate the electronic states
so this is infinite dimensional and i
want to learn the map from f to this
electronic states and we use the same
architecture on this side here we don't
need any pca because it's already finite
dimensional but here we do
and okay so that's what we do the same
architecture as before so this is the
ground truth this is the prediction this
is the error
and here's really what i found very
remarkable so we were trying to
calculate energy
so this is the ml if i learn the energy
directly
this is the
energy so this is really a map from a
finite dimensional to a finite
dimensional so it's a classical neural
net
in this particular example you can get
pretty good errors
which are acceptable
but if i learn the electronic fields
and then use that electronic field to
calculate the energy you can see i
really can remarkably reduce the amount
of error that i have from here to here
so what it is telling you the fact that
you can learn this kind of solution
operator gives you very significant
error and in a way what it also shows
you not only that
you can use ml
to learn but the solution but you could
if if you really want very high accuracy
you can also use it like a
preconditioner
so you can
because the methods you use often are
iterative and so if you have a good
initial guess or a preconditioner that
is a very significant thing and in a way
i interpret this machine learning as a
preconditioner because we do one
self-consistent loop after that
so the third example i want to go and
i'll spend some time on this and really
talk about multi-scale modeling is
crystal plasticity
and so
what you have is you have a unit south
here some three by three or two by two
unit cell
you have multiple grains
and in each grain you have a very large
number of slip systems and twin systems
in this case each grain had something
like 48 twin and slip systems so because
this is a symmetric crystal
so all the grains have the same physics
but their orientation is different
you're given this stress history and
you're trying to predict uh sorry the
strain history of the deformation
gradient history and you're trying to
predict the stress
right
so the initial microstructure is given
we subject it to some deformation and we
are trying to predict the stress
okay so that's what okay so this is your
strain history this is the stress
history
so the question is what is the sample or
what is the distribution from which i
want to sample my deformation gradient
history right and this is the sampling
we chose
we took this time interval 0 to t
chopped it up into n segments
and then we did a gaussian process on
that and smoothed it so it can go up and
down in each of its components
that's what we chose
we tried both
having kind of
uniform time segments
and
random time segments and i'll show you
both
that's how we generate the data
and i'm going to show you data for both
2d fft full resolution calculations and
3d
where the data is generated by taylor
averaging
so that's kind of
what we did okay
now notice that what i have really is
i need the stress
the deformation gradient history up till
time t and i give you the time t
but the architecture i have is for
functions from one fixed interval to a
fixed interval so that's what we are
that's what our data is
and we're learning this function so in
some ways there is no reason why this
operator would have to be causal but the
physics is constant right so
uh
so that's something
the we don't assume that
our architecture is causal and one of
the tests would be whether we learn
causality from the data
okay
so here's kind of the example so this is
the input
and you can this is the output so this
is the truth and the approximation so we
do reasonably well both with fixed and
random
and this shows you some summary of how
well we do in learning and let me focus
on the 3d
so if both your
test data and training data
is
sampled on a random
intervals
then
with training with 30 000
packs
gives you a pca error of about 10
percent uh gives you not a pc error but
it gives you a total error of about 10
so that actually 10 looks large but it
actually looks something like this so
you get very reasonable solutions from
this
okay
again the same thing that we have
checked with resolution
so this is what you would get
um it's the error is resolution
independent and again you see with the
different
pca dimensions you get
different errors
now one point i wanted to make here was
that the error really comes from the
okay so we have errors of the pca and we
have errors at the neural network and
the errors large errors are really on
the neural network the pca error is here
this is the total error so the dominant
source of the error is in the training
of the neural network
here's some kind of common
paths which we use in mechanics to
test constitutive models so those are
some facts
and here's showing you that
even though our architecture is not
causal the data teaches the network uh
the operator the causality so
so here's
multiple paths all of which up till time
tb are the same and then they diverge
and we find that you see that
this is the learned
you all these paths
remain exactly the same up till that
point and then
the div
so despite the fact that we're training
on the whole interval
in this region where all the paths were
the same all the responses are the same
showing that it really did learn
causality here's the other test
i have multiple tests where
each of them the first one goes up till
here then oops sorry
uh departs
then the second part goes up till here
and then departs the third part goes up
to there and then departs and again you
see that it really does learn
in the causal part in the parts which
are common it actually follows this
common trajectory and departs only when
the input trajectory departs
so
you can do other obvious checks learning
symmetries learning other things that we
know from kind of physics that should be
true and it
all of that works very well
we also then went ahead and then they
said okay let's really try to see
whether i can use it in an fv square
mapping
what we did was we wrote our
neural operator as a
user material in abacus why abacus
because that's what we wanted that's
what we used
and uh so basically now we have an ml
surrogate
which is serving as our material model
uh
and here's some simulation so this is
the kind of punch with
so you train the vu mat with
and once you write it you can change
boundary conditions you can do punches
with different plate thickness you can
do the taylor impact again with
different size and
you can look at it in many different
ways and it's
it works quite well so what's the cost
so this is the cost
so let me look at the taylor anvil
we ran it on a single processor using
abacus if i use a classical constitutive
model like johnson cook
it in this particular processor it took
about 50
seconds
if we did our
trained view mat it takes about nine
times that and it's the same thing for
the plate impact and we have tried many
ways many other problems and it's always
factors somewhere between factor eight
to ten somewhere in there
okay you have to pay a one-time
offline cost for
one time cost for training the data and
that was 10 to the six
and the offline training
the so offline cost of generating the
data which was 10 to the 6
and the offline cost of training which
is 10 to the 4 but on a gpu so you let's
take it back to 100 just to kind of
okay this is large
but on the other hand if i really did a
concurrent or an fe square calculation a
single calculation would have taken me
10 to the 8.
so i'm getting the accuracy of
concurrent model which would have cost
me 10 to the 8 at a cost which is
comparable to the traditional model so
this really is an effective architecture
and i'll show you
another architecture soon which we're
working on at the moment where
this number gets knocked down to
something which is very comparable to
this
so this becomes an effective tool for
doing multi-scale modeling okay
so that's what i wanted to say so it's
an effective approach so you can really
get accuracies comparable to concurrent
multi-scale
with the cost of traditional
constitutive relation
but there are problems with the
architecture i showed you
you really have to know the entire
history so you somehow have to know the
duration a priority
and so if you want to do a calculation
which is longer than that
you can't use this network so that's one
problem so one question you can ask is
can i learn a markovian approximation
where
given the current state i can predict
the update
and we'll come back to that in a second
in this particular case i have to
train a material model for every virgin
material because i'm mapping the strain
history to the stress history so one of
our active areas of work is try to
understand
what about the microstructure what is
we have to keep track of which what
aspects of the microstructure do we have
to keep track of
okay then there is also
in the
large scale problem we
in the fine scale problem
we did not keep track of inertia so
that's uh
okay so we'll have to
figure that out and okay
there are other applications which we
have which we're working on but i want
to focus a little bit on this can i find
a markovian approximation or in some
ways it's also related to the next
question here can you learn something
hidden about the physics that you didn't
know about
so we thought about it and so again
we're trying to learn
what i showed you was learning
the entire map now the question is can i
learn it from an update if i give you a
strain update
can you calculate the stress update from
a model like this
well you need something about
the state of the microstructure so you
need something about the current state
and it has to give you the new state so
but i don't want to make an assumption
of it i don't want to make this known a
priory i would like to learn it so the
question is can i also learn this hidden
state variable
so we took some
inspiration from mechanics how we
formulate macroscopic models and we said
okay let's try the following
architecture
i'm going to say that the stress at time
t
will depend on the deformation gradient
at time t
some rate of change of deformation
gradient at time t
some hidden variable c
and the hidden variable
evolves according to some first other
dynamics so it's some kind of overdone
over-damped dynamics for the
hidden variable it's a very common
structure that we use in mechanics and
material science
so landau ginsberg models all of these
we use so can we see whether
that architecture works
of course the point is we don't know the
function f and g
and we don't know the hidden variable
zeta
right
so what we would like to learn is
use our training data set to learn
these functions f and g
theta
and this hidden variable
c
uh zeta sorry uh this in variable zeta
so that's what we'd like to do and when
we started testing it on some simple 1d
viscoelastic models
so okay so it's 1d so the stress depends
on the elastic modulus which might be
spatially dependent
and some viscosity which again might be
so in this case
with we can prove an approximation
theorem with this particular
architecture
where we use very essentially some of
the
features of this model
but this is what we learn
so if i don't use any hidden variable
then i get a large error if i use one
hidden variable i get a smaller error
and more or less the data in this
particular example
you learn from using
about three hidden variables so it
begins to learn the data with three
hidden variables
the architecture i used here was strain
rate dependent
but suppose i don't have this
it turns out that
it becomes the error becomes resolution
dependent whereas
if i use the strain rate
in my architecture it becomes resolution
independent and
we know from the approximation theorem
that that has to be the case so this is
kind of the numerical test
we also did this on 1d viscoplasticity a
very simple model
and
so here
there's no averaging so we know that
there is only one state variable and the
question is can you find it
and we can show that the error best
approximation is with one
hidden variable
and in fact the hidden variable up to
some in essential constant tracks the
plastic strain which is the hidden
variable in the model that i start so i
want to emphasize that what we are
providing it is
epsilon as a function of t and sigma is
a function of t and it is learning
epsilon p from that data
and we have now extended it to 3d poly
crystals and are implementing it and
we're trying to understand
the errors and in fact our preliminary
tests as i mentioned earlier are really
very encouraging where we are able to
learn a lot about the macroscopic
plasticity
so we are following a similar approach
in trying to learn
the texture problems so to try to learn
the dependence on the microstructure
and so hopefully in about a year or a
couple of years we'll have some
uh
be able to update you
so um in the last five minutes or so um
if if i may or
i'm happy to stop here or
wanted to make a couple of comments
about uh
physical hat yeah
thank you about a more general how this
fits into a more general i showed you a
couple of particular architectures but i
wanted to make you a uh comments about
the more general about neural operator
so we've been this is the kind of maps
that we are interested in from some
function space to another
and so as a general architecture this is
what we have been studying
so if you recall in the pcnet i had a i
had a projection here and a lifting here
and then i had a neural net in the
middle
so more generally what we want to do is
the following
so we still have some kind of linear
operator but it's local so in other
words
if i give you some
function it
p only b at any point x only acts at
that point x so it's a very local
operator
the middle layer is you have some
activation function your favorite one
then you have a local operator l some
bias w so
that is exactly what i showed you
but then we add a non-local integral
operator here
right so at any given point
kv returns a value which samples not
only x but all its entire neighborhood
and the other one you could do is rather
kv would be the inverse fourier
transform of a linear transform of the
fourier transform of v
right so it would be something like that
okay
and for this we can go ahead and prove
an approximation theorem
it says that if f and s are bonus spaces
and phi is continuous on these bondok
spaces and maps between monarch spaces
we need some technical hypothesis which
um
i've omitted
then you can prove
an approximation theorem that we do
indeed have a neural network and a
training which provides you with an
error and here it is the soup error over
some compact set
so this holds for the previous pc and
net as well and so this is actually
so it extends the previous theorem but
it extends to
all theorems all kind of architectures
of this class
which
so i thought i'll show you one example
of this it's the so-called what we call
the graph kernel network
where okay so we have an integral
operator
and okay i don't know how to my data is
already might be discrete so and i don't
want to evaluate this whole integral so
we do some nistrum approximation at some
points
and then i can also incorporate
multi-grid structure to it so basically
the
the value at this point comes so in
other words the value at this point
comes from some neighboring points here
it comes from some other neighboring
points here you can use multiple
resolution and this gives you a very
strong architecture
it turns out that you can show that
the mod if
okay so you can show that this requires
much less data to train
you can get super resolution
but it turns out that the evaluation of
networks like this is much more
expensive so in the case of multi-scale
modeling where i want to use this in a
larger scale model and i have to use it
evaluated repeatedly it becomes
completely prohibitive
but in areas where i'm trying to learn
from sparse data
where i might have some on
data from a smaller resolution and i'm
trying to understand the solution
operator this becomes an extremely
powerful method and that's something
as a way of doing
multi-resolution calculation and that's
something that we have been kind of
trying to explore
and some other comments i wanted to make
but uh
i'll skip over that
and i'll stop here
uh
with a list of
much of this work actually all of this
work is certainly available in pre-prep
some of it is published but much of it
is available in preprint form of the
archives so i'll leave this slide up and
i'm happy to answer any questions or
um
uh receive any comments and suggestions
thank you thank you
thank you so much for the wonderful talk
kaushik um i loved it a lot we do have a
question from um
so rav
he asked can an operator that maps
multiple input functions to multiple
output functions b learned this way
it means pca nat
and would there need to be any
assumption on the spaces that the input
and output functions need to lie in
okay
so the answer to the first part of the
question is yes so
you know um
i if i have multiple input functions and
multiple output functions i'll think of
that as a higher dimensional input
function and a higher dimensional output
function if i can think of that way this
architecture works there's no
limitation on the dimension of the input
function so in fact
when i talked about the strain space to
stress space
i'm mapping from a nine dimensional
space to a nine dimensional space so
okay
and
in the case of the dft calculation for
example my output was multiple things
multiple components of the electronic
structure and you can you can use this
now
as i mentioned
you're
you're learning so you really need to
know somehow the distribution from which
your data is coming from right and you
need to know that you're sampling
a meaningful sample that your sample
size is
test
sufficient
and while we have these universal
approximation theorems
they tell they tell you about existence
right it tells you that there exists
something it doesn't tell you how to
find it or when it is sufficient right
and that's one of the kind of big open
questions in the field and
everything we do suffers from that as
well
all right sounds good okay another
question from king kai
can you also uh comment on the fourier
neural operators and also the neural
operators on nonlinear ptes
yeah so on the fourier neural operators
and the
graph kernel
operators
uh
we have tested this on
okay
a linear pde but the map is non-linear
right it's from the coefficient to the
solution so that's the one i showed you
in fact actually maybe i will i think i
have a backup slide from our recent
paper there
yeah so i had this so this was the
solution from
the error in the solution from the
uh
a of x to you so that's
the pd is linear but the the mapping i'm
trying to learn is non-linear
and okay so
this is resolution various resolutions
and these are the errors for a given
data set so and this was a very small
data set
and
you know the fourier neural operator and
the graph neural operator really does
very well
because you're really learning in
essence the greens function of the
solution operator so with very small
amounts of data you can really learn it
it provides super resolution as i showed
um but
you have to take a free transform so
that's expensive or you have to evaluate
a cur you know you have to do an
integral operator so it's expensive so
in the context of multi-scale modeling
it's not the greatest thing but if
you're really trying to learn the pde
um we have also done this uh for
learning the burgers equation and then
uh and navier stokes and once again the
fourier neural operator does very well
in those
pdes
um and the graph kernel does um not as
well but very good uh as well so these
numbers are representative of not only
this example but the burgers equation
and uh
and
navier stokes with uh
with limited um
reynolds number i actually forget of the
top of my head what the maximum reynolds
numbers we went to
okay
thank you so much
my question is can you go back to the
slide
okay slide
20. you go yeah
oh yeah here um so you you compare the
the computation of course the various
computational quotes that
that is nice
and i have a two questions on on this
slide and the first one is the offline
data
well generations and offline training
it's it's a multi-scale so you you train
the um
the neural net on on the on the micro
scale it is the you know the small
compared to the the macro scale system
levels
that's right so i i was expecting
you know
somewhat efficient training procedure
because the data size you're dealing
with is smaller but maybe you are
you need a lot of data
so yes okay very good question um so
what we needed in this case
with this pca net architecture was
uh of the order of 10 000 i don't
remember exactly the number 10 000
trajectory so i had to do 10 000
calculations
and this is the estimated cost on a
single cpu right i mean that so i wanted
to keep everything so i said okay if it
if i had done each of these calculations
on a single cpu what would it cost and
that was this 10 to the six to generate
the data
add them up okay now
of course i can do this trivially
parallely because it's independent
realizations
right right
and
with the kind of um
recurrent neural operators we find
much better accuracy with just 400
trajectories because it's
it's learning much more the structure of
the problem here it is not learning the
structure of the problem
so
in this particular case this number is
large
uh
but i think
this is something we can knock down with
a better architecture and also underst
doing better data science of trying to
sample in a better way okay i guess it
can be improved
absolutely and uh for the problem with
the rno net some of the tests we're
doing you knock it down by a factor uh
by
it's about of the order of um
of a thousand if i remember correctly so
it's knocks down by fact uh by
uh 10 to the three
okay sounds good so yeah my second
question on this slide is okay so you
nicely have the comparison between the
concurrent multi-scale and
your data-driven
the multi-scale
the results
on the computational cost how about the
accuracy
um
so how different are they
okay good question uh
we never did the concurrent multiscale
right this is the estimated based on the
number of elements and the number of
realizations i would have to do
but but i expect accuracy to be good
because what i've done is i've i have
done a lot of testing of the model
itself
right so the model itself is very
accurate
and so basically
it's basically replacing one material
model with another
and if the material models are the same
the integration schemes are the same i
would expect the same accuracy so
while in this context i have not done
the full comparison
um
i would expect even in this that would
be the case we have done the full
comparison
in simpler 1d problems and it bears it
out very okay
you know being at a university i don't
always have the computational resources
that you guys have so yeah well
multiscale is not something i could
yeah simulate
yeah well for that and um we can
collaborate of course
i would be delighted to do that yeah we
do have machines and you do have the
algorithms so we can of course now yeah
now i would love to do that yeah
all right sounds good all right um
thank you so much how is there any other
questions from audiences that you can
unmute yourself and
directly
if you do have one
otherwise let's thank our speaker for
the wonderful talk and i loved it i
learned a lot and i especially like the
the pre-conditioner
the perspective um
so
very
very well done thank you so much
it's a pleasure and
if you don't mind at some point you
might sending me the link of the talk
yeah yeah i will definitely do so yeah
great thank you
bye thank you thank you